Adam and eve,
right?
The mother and father of all humanity.
So you could give them a nephrological
slat and you can say Adam is cultured.
Say and Eve is nature because
they're the archetipal parents.
It's a perfectly
reasonable interpretation.
They have twin sons,
Cain and Abel.
So let's read first born creatures,
first born human creatures in
the new self conscious world.
So what are the first two individuals
in the new self conscious world like?
And let's find out.
And Adam knew eve,
his wife,
and she conceived and Bare Cain and said,
I have gotten a man from the Lord.
And again,
she bare his brother Abel,
the younger brother and
Abel was a keeper of sheep.
But Cain was a tiller of the ground.
And in the process of time it came to
pass that Cain brought of the fruit of the
ground,
an offering unto the Lord.
Okay,
so we're going to remove this from,
it's
his story from its entrapment in a
particular temporal domain within a 10 or
culture when to say something like this.
Well,
if you work,
you make sacrifices,
right?
That's what works all about.
And the reason you make sacrifices is
because you're offering up to the unknown,
the fruits of your labor in the hope
that as a consequence of your diligent
effort,
you're going to be favored,
right?
Because otherwise,
why work?
The point of working is to transform the
transcendent into something benevolent.
So you work and you work
and you work and you say,
is that sufficient?
And the answer you get from
the transcendent is the answer.
Now,
it's certainly true that
lots of people work.
It doesn't go all that well,
right?
They make sacrifices and they do what
they think they have to do in their life
is one string of
catastrophes after another,
right?
So we have this situation
in the process of time,
it came to pass that Cain brought
of the fruit of the ground,
an offering unto the Lord and Abel.
He also brought of the firstlings
of his flock and of the fat thereof.
And the Lord had respect
unto Abel and his offering.
So what that means is that Oh,
they able working away,
Bam,
things are going great for him,
right?
Fortune smiles on him.
He's doing wonderfully.
He's got everything he needs.
Well,
old cane,
he's scrounging away in the ground and
things aren't going as well for him at
all,
right?
Plagues locusts,
you name it.
Farm life isn't going well.
So what happens?
Oh,
Cain was very wroth and his
countenance fell precisely,
right?
Because if you work diligently towards
a certain end and you don't get there,
then you're continents fell.
Falls,
right?
You're angry,
frustrated,
disappointed,
hurt,
anxious,
threatened,
ashamed,
guilty.
The whole panoply of negative emotions.
And that's fair enough
because of course if you fail,
that's sweats going to be the consequence.
But then there's this little twist on it,
right?
This specifically human twist it.
It's like that kind of
moral of the whole story.
And so you find the Lord saying,
oh well,
you know,
what's,
what's up with you?
Why are you so unhappy?
If you just got your act together,
then you'd be accepted if you
really got your act together,
which is a statement,
something like this.
If you keep making sacrifices and the
same terrible thing keeps happening,
there's always the possibility that you're
just actually not doing it the right
way.
And if you just get
yourself straightened up,
tap together,
right?
And drop the preconceptions that you
don't really need and adjust your behavior
accordingly.
Then fortune would smile on you.
And that's exactly what
the Lord says to Cain,
right?
You don't walk around with such
a crabby look on your face.
If you did well,
you'll be accepted.
And if you don't do well,
sin lies at the door.
So what does that mean?
Well,
this is a deep motif in
ancient Hebrew thinking.
If the world isn't laying itself out
in a manner that you find acceptable,
you're faced with a tough choice.
Either the world is a terrible
place bent on your destruction,
or you're doing something wrong and it
bloody well better be that you're doing
something wrong.
Because if the world is a terrible
place bent on your destruction,
you've got absolutely no hope.
And Kate and talk with Abel,
his brother,
and it came to pass when they were in
the field that Cain rose up against Abel,
his brother,
and killed him.
So what does that mean?
Well,
it's pretty easy.
It's simple.
It means this will say things
aren't going that well for you.
And it's really not because life's unfair
and everything's stacked against you.
It's because you're kind of a arrogant,
stubborn,
because I totalitarian,
cowardly idiot.
And as a consequence of that,
the world is turning into something
resembling a wasteland around you and you
have this option change.
Okay.
Or continue.
Or You have another option,
man,
look around.
There's all those people doing well.
The world's a terrible place
bans on my destruction.
Wouldn't it be just the
most interesting thing?
If as things are going to hell for me,
I could take along just for the ride.
Some of those successful people who
are successful just for unfair reasons
anyways,
right?
So instead of using all that negative
emotion has a cue that there's something
about me that might
need to be transformed.
I can say,
well,
okay,
why not just eradicate the
target of my resentment,
right?
Not only because that sort of
removes the problem of comparison,
but more profoundly.
And I think sort of again,
eliminate honestly profoundly.
Let's say you make the decision that
the world's a terrible place and it's on
your destruction,
and then you think,
well,
what's the logical response to that?
And then you think something like this.
Yeah.
Girtha foes,
Mephistopheles Credo.
This spirit I that endlessly
denies and rightly too,
for all that comes to birth is fit for
overthrow as nothing worth wherefore the
world,
we're better sterilized.
Thus all that's here is evil.
Recognized is gained to me and downfall,
rune and sin,
the very element I prosper in
and
girth draws our attention to this credo.
Not once,
but twice in his writing a file.
Austin has Mephistopheles
say right once again,
go on to share.
Nothing passed with no made one.
What matters?
Our creative,
endless toil.
When add a snapchat,
oblivion ends the coil,
it is by gone.
I'll show this riddle run as good
as if things never had begun yet.
Circle back existence to possess.
I'd rather have eternal emptiness.
And so then you think about cane,
like figures like Stella and you think,
well what exactly was he motivated by?
And on the one hand you think,
well,
he was trying to extend
his cultural dominion,
right?
Played by his own self
conscious neuroticism.
He wanted to extend the,
the,
the borders of his totalitarian certainty
to every corner just to not be plagued
by the unknown.
And you think,
fair enough.
You know,
like we're all pretty nervous and
a little stability is a good thing.
Why?
Because they make a fundamental judgment,
which is the judgment of Mephistopheles.
Look,
life is terrible,
terrible,
terrible were self conscious.
We get sick,
we go insane.
We're going to die.
Children,
innocent children suffer everywhere.
How in the world is it right
to let such a state continue?
Maybe it would be better.
All things considered just to
bring the whole game to an end.
And so then you think again with Haley
Adda that the reason that human societies
fall apart is twofold.
One is things go from bad to
worse of their own accord,
right?
Thermodynamic reality,
pure entropy,
structured entities decay.
But then there's a twist.
Structured entities constructed by humans
are sped in their process of decay by
the participants of the
individuals within that society.
Who have essentially decided that the
game is not worth the price and that under
such conditions,
the only reasonable thing
for a self conscious,
painfully self conscious individual
to do is to work as hard as he or she
possibly can to take the maximum
amount of revenge on the conditions of
existence and to ensure that
the entire game folds up,
the consciousness disappears,
and the being is eradicated.